Over my career acquiring and scaling
businesses foracquisition.com, I've done
a lot of deals. I want to put the five
most brutally effective tactics that I
know in one video for you. A lot of
these things I didn't actually learn
from books. I learned them from mentors
and actually seeing them do it and
learning like in the streets in the real
world. Most itty bitty tactics like
don't actually drive the needle. But
these five actually have gotten deals
done and improve my situation or
standing in the deal. So, let's dive in.
There's three contexts that you're going
to use each of these skills with. The
first is with employees, and this goes
both ways. If you're an employee trying
to negotiate with an employer, then that
applies. The second is going to be
vendors. Now, this also applies if
you're a vendor who's dealing with
customers. And then third, you've got
what I would consider partners. This is
when you do deals, M&A, things like
that, investment. So, these are kind of
the three big vectors that all of this
stuff applies to. So, if you're like,
I'm not sure if this will work for me,
you for sure, even if you don't have a
business, you are an employee. And if
you are an employee and you don't want
to use that, you certainly have vendors
that come to your house and do things
for you. Like this is the fruit of life.
You have to negotiate and you get what
you negotiate, not what you deserve.
That may sound not fair, but it's also
the truth. Number one, this is actually
from a Harvard Business School thing
that I learned from Chiron Cervata. It's
called BATNA. Now, I didn't know the
fancy term for it, but it means best
alternative to a negotiated agreement.
So, what does this really mean? Research
has shown that having strong BATNA,
basically a strong alternative, gives
you significant leverage in
negotiations. Negotiations is all about
leverage. London Business School did a
study and they found that negotiators
who know their alternatives set higher
aspirations. So they ask for more. They
make more aggressive first offers and
they negotiate ultimately better
outcomes. So your BATNA serves as almost
like an anchor, a counter anchor that
you have in the back of your mind of
what you're negotiating with. It's kind
of like a source of power. It's a
decision standard that you only accept
deals that are better than your best
alternative. You can think about this in
any setting. So, if you're with a girl
and you know that you can only date
tens. If a seven comes along, you're
like, "Well, my alternative is a 10, so
I'm only dealing with tens." If someone
says, "Hey, I'll be willing to buy all
of your inventory for 10 bucks a piece."
And somebody else comes along and says,
"I'll do it for nine." Instead of just
saying no, you're like, "I'll do it for$
1050 or I'll do it for 11." You can edge
them up. But if you know that it's not
going to matter, then it doesn't matter.
So, I'll tell you something that
recently happened. I'm right now
negotiating to buy a home. It's
something that Ila wants and it's
aggressive. We already have a home that
we like a lot. I really like the house
we have. My best alternative to buying
this house is doing nothing and just
enjoying the home that I already have.
They're in a terrible position because
right now I know that they haven't had
anyone else who's bid on the property
because it's aggressively priced. I'll
put it that way. It's them versus me and
it's who wants it less. The reason
badness is so important, you're like,
"Okay, I get that. How do I have a best
alternative to a negotiated agreement?"
You win negotiations, and I'm starting
with this one because I think it it's
all five of the or six ones that I'm
going to show you are going to be so
important, but this one is probably the
greatest source of psychological power.
And you do this before you sit down to
the table. Me going to look at these
homes, I know I don't have to buy the
homes. When I was selling Gym Launch and
Prestige Labs, I was like, I can just
keep the businesses and they'll just
keep making me money. I don't need to
sell them. And from negotiating for that
position, you only want to sell when you
don't want to sell. You want to buy when
you don't want to buy because you have
something else. If you're looking for
jobs as an employee, you want to
negotiate when you already have another
offer. So, if you're going to your
existing employer, get another offer and
then negotiate with that. You can only
do that so many times before you start
losing goodwill. So, you have to make
sure that you're balancing that well. If
you're dealing with a vendor, then
you're like, "Okay, I'm going to get
multiple bids before I'm going to decide
to work with you because these are what
I'm considering." You'll get so educated
from actually negotiating four, five,
six of these vendor agreements that
you'll learn other terms that other
people include that you can use, which
is a later strategy that I'll explain.
Getting multiple offers before you sit
down increases your bet. So, for sure,
don't take the first offer because even
if you have first offer within the
negotiation with one guy, but then you
have that offer compared to all the
other offers you're ultimately going to
get to do the work. On the vendor side,
it's reversed. What's my best
alternative? What are my other
customers? If I've got 20 other
customers, I got people banging on the
door. It's a supply demand thing. So,
I've got more demand for my services
than I have supply. And so, if you don't
want it, don't worry. I've got another
customer behind you. And so, this is the
leverage that we go back and forth in
negotiations. And then, finally, with
partnerships, the same idea. How can I
get multiple offers from people wanting
to buy my business? And to the same
degree for me, if I'm trying to buy a
business, then I want to not have to buy
the business because I got other
businesses I'm looking at. So, no matter
what, all of this is one before you sit
down to the table. Right now, if you sit
down and you need this deal and you have
no other offers, all the little tactics
that you can try, sure, you can try to
do it, but the thing is that it's just
trying to win at poker only on bluffing.
It's a bad position to be in. I would
rather have pocket aces. If you have
other offers, there's two different ways
of thinking about this. So, one is you
can be overt about it and say, "Listen,
this is the counter offer. If you can
beat the offer, beat it. If you can't,
no worries. We don't need to waste
time." The other way is that you just
have it in the back of your mind and
then you just see what you can get.
Because the thing is, somebody else is
giving you a $10 offer. If you say,
"Hey, I've got a $10 offer, maybe this
person will just beat it by 1025." But
if you have the confidence that you know
you're going to sell the inventory no
matter what for a profit, shoot for 11,
shoot for 12, shoot for 15. Like you can
shoot way higher because you know your
plan B is not bad. And so when you show
it, they're just going to basically
marginally edge it versus you having the
confidence to basically swing big. Real
quick, if you're a business owner and
you are not growing as fast as you'd
like, I'd like to give you a free gift.
So my team and I put together the $100
million scaling roadmap, which is
basically 200 hours of us looking over
all the portfolio companies we've had
and what stages of growth they went
through and more importantly where they
got stuck and how they got past it. And
so we broke it into these 10 stages and
we made this little kind of quiz thing
where if you put in your business
information, it'll tell you where you're
at and the most important part for you,
what to do for each of functions of the
business across product, marketing,
sales, customer success, recruiting, IT,
human resources, and finance. And so no
matter what you're struggling with,
someone else has already struggled with
it and solved it. And so I'd like to
give you this thing absolutely free. You
can go to
acquisition.com/roadmap, plug in your
business information. And if you want us
to actually help you deconstrain the
business and you're trying to scale,
we'd love to help you out on the thank
you page. You can just book a call with
my team and we will look at the
business, see if we can help, and if we
can, we'll invite you out to Vegas and
we'll do this in person live. So if
that's cool, hit the link. Otherwise,
enjoy the rest of the video. Now, the
second is a big one, and a lot of
negotiation books and courses and stuff
talk about this, and people are like,
"Hey, I'm not trying to anchor here." It
doesn't matter if you say, "I'm not
trying to anchor here." It's an anchor.
An anchor is the first number that is
set in a negotiation. If you're like,
"Hey, what do you think you'd be willing
to do this for?" And someone's like,
"Ah, I was thinking I could maybe do it
for $2,000." That's now the anchor. You
want to get less than that, and you were
like, "Shoot, I was hoping for 500."
Well, something you should have said 500
first because now their 2,000s seem
ridiculous. There is a strategy called
counter anchoring, but it's typically
not as effective as anchoring, but it's
the only move you have left. Now, the
flip side is the reason a lot of people
don't want to put the anchor out is
because they don't want to short change.
If someone was going to say yes to
5,000, you put 2,000 out there, you're
like, damn, because whatever happens is
if someone gives you a fast yes, you're
like, "No, I left so much money on the
table." So, I'll give you a little pro
tip that I've learned being on the other
side of this. If I have somebody who
comes to me and says, "Hey, I'll do it
for $2,000." And I would have paid five
and I say, "Yeah, $2,000 works." The
next thing I do is I say, "Hey, and if
you were curious of whether I would do
it for 2500, I wouldn't have done it."
And the thing is that it puts them at
ease that like, you know what, you
wouldn't have done more. And what
happened is I bought a super expensive
penthouse a few years ago. And after I
bought it, the guy who sold it to me,
obviously a wealthy guy, too. He said,
"Hey, we accepted your first offer and
you're probably wondering if we would
have done it for less." He said, "I
wouldn't have sold it for a penny less."
It felt so classy. Maybe he would have
sold it for penny less. I have no idea.
But in the moment it actually like I was
like okay it just made me feel a lot
better. So if you're in the reverse
situation I would put someone at ease by
just saying hey I wouldn't have done it
for any less or I wouldn't have done it
for anymore or whatever. What's
interesting is that Daniel Nobel's prize
winner figured out that people give
excessive weight to the initial
information and make insufficient
adjustments from that starting point.
It's a psychological bias. Basically
it's like you want to anchor as high as
possible. That's why I'm a big advocate
of getting the gasp. put the big number
out there because it completely shifts
the whole negotiation numbers to way way
higher and the things people think in
different increments and that's what we
want to change. If you say I'll do this
work for $100,000, whatever you're in
construction, if someone was thinking
10, their increments now become the
entirety of what they were willing to
pay. They're going to be like, can you
do it for 80? All of a sudden, we're
thinking in $20,000 increments. As a
side note, you can also anchor
increments. So, explain what that means.
I'll actually walk you through the house
negotiation that I'm actively in right
now. The house was listed at 25 million.
Then they dropped it to 20 million
because the markets changed and things
like that. Okay. So now they're at 20
million. So I made an offer for 15
million. They countered and said we'll
do it for$69. So big move on their part,
right? They're moving aggressively.
They're trying to sell the house. They
moved a lot towards me because they're
trying to get a deal done. The natural
thing that some people might think is
okay, they're at 17, you're at 15.
Counter with 16 here. So what I did is I
countered with 15.25.
So they moved three million, I moved up
250 grand. Thing is that there's this
idea of like movement. If you make an
offer, I make an offer. So if I say
15.25, what am I indicating? I'm not
willing to move very much. I'm going to
out of reciprocity, which we'll cover
later. I'm willing to move a little bit.
I'm going to make some counter offer,
but I'm not going to give a lot. Then I
can stack in other terms that make it
more amarable for them. My initial
offer, I had two other things. I was
like, okay, I can offer cash. My first
offer is not going to be cash. I can
also say, hey, it has furnishings in the
house which are super expensive. I don't
want to have to deal with refernishing
the house. What I did was when I moved
up to 15.25, I sweetened the deal by
making it all cash. But then I also
said, I also want the $4 million of
furniture that's in the house, which is
technically a worse second offer than my
first offer. But the thing is that I
moved the number up and a lot of people
are always way too fixated on the price
and not enough on the terms. One is we
anchor with our original price and also
in the increments that we move in. And
this was something that took me actually
a while to figure out. And so let me
tell you a story about this one. So, one
of my partners at my gym way back in the
day, I learned this from him. He had to
get this big custom front desk built.
So, it had like multiple cutouts. We had
multiple sales people. Big impressive
thing. You get a custom built. The guy
came out, they built this whole thing.
He was like, "Hey, when we went to do
like the final inspection, we noticed
that they had kind of like nicked a
corner of it just from moving it around
or whatever happened, right? It was a
small nick, but it was noticeable." My
partner goes to the guy and he says,
"Hey, how much would it cost you to
replace this?" And the guy, of course,
because he doesn't want to rebuild the
whole thing. He's, "Oh my god, it would
be a huge deal for us to have to like
just this little thing. We'd have to go
back to the shop. We have to do this
stuff. It would probably cost us $1,500
just to replace that." And he says,
"That sounds like a pretty good place to
start it for a
discount." Nasty. I was like, "Oh, I'm
going to use that." If there's ever
someone who messes something up, instead
of saying, "Hey, what can you knock off
the price?" Ask them what the big
inconvenience would be for them, ascribe
a price to it. And then they have a hard
time backing down from that cuz they
just said that's how much it would cost
them to fix it. Then you should probably
discount us by that much because that
was the size of the mess up. So you get
them bidding for themselves and then you
flip it. So number three, I learned this
from a different mentor. They call it
misos, but basically multiple equivalent
simultaneous offers. So what does that
mean? That means that I
present offer
A, offer
B, and offer C. Or just offer A and B.
It doesn't really matter. You can have
two offers. You can have three offers
and each of these have different prices
and terms associated with them. And so
what happens is when you make multiple
equivalent offers, it's like embedding
reciprocity. It's like, hey, I'm trying
to be reasonable. I just want to figure
out what works best for you because all
three of these work for me, but which
one's better? This is a way of actually
teasing out what someone else's
priorities are if they're not willing to
tell you because a lot of times you want
to hold your card close and not say,
"What are the things that are most
valuable to you?" Now, over time, you
build some trust, you build some
rapport, and you will be able to share
because ideally something that's
important to you is not important to
them. and they give you this one and
something that's born to them, it's not
born to you, you give to them. And
that's fundamentally a good negotiation.
And one of the big things that I
misunderstood in the beginning is that I
assumed negotiation was a zero- sum
game. And it's never a zero- sum game
because you're a different person. You
have different needs. You're always
going to have some things that will be
more important to you than other people.
And in that situation, it's like you
want to just interlock the things that
matter most to each person. That's where
it becomes a positive sum game. Both
parties are better off from basically
giving and taking in places that are
less meaningful to them and more
meaningful to the other person. Journal
of Personality and Social Psychology
showed that presenting multiple
equivalent offers simultaneously
increases the likelihood of finding
mutually beneficial solutions. This
approach demonstrates flexibility while
also maintaining your core interest
because you're the one who's presenting
all the offers. It's almost like a
reverse assumed close. Hey, I'll do any
of these three things and you just pick
the one that works for you. And then the
thing is they're picking all any of
these I said already worked for me. Let
me give you like a real world example.
So let's say option A is lower monthly
fee with a longer commitment. Option B
is a higher monthly fee but has premium
support. And then option C is kind of
like a pay as you go with slightly
higher rates but maximum flexibility.
Right? So all three options will give
you similar overall value but you might
look at them and be like I just want to
know which one meets your needs better.
From their answers you'll be able to
understand their motivations. Now let me
tell you some knowledge from the street.
If someone gives you multiple offers, if
you're on the other side of the table,
what I like to do is say, "I like the
best part of this one, and I like the
best part of this one. And why don't we
make an offer that is the best of all
three?" And I learned this from my
friend Shiron. Guy's done more deals
than anyone I know. I was like, "Oo,
that's good." So, the flip side is you
could ask someone, "Hey, can you give me
two or three versions of what this deal
might look like?" And then they come up
with their versions of the deals. And
then you say, "Great, I like this piece.
How about we do option D?" And what's
nice about this is it also shows some
active listing for you. You countering
with something like this or even taking
two of the three components. Two of
those components might be meaningful for
you and not for them again because they
put them in the different deals. You
might find out that you can get more of
the things that you want just by asking.
So number four, reciprocity. Now
reciprocity is key in all sorts of
persuasion. And I'll say this one caveat
that I believe reciprocity only matters
in cultures where reciprocity matters.
There are cultures where reciprocity is
not nearly as important. This is where
sometimes when cultures mix, people take
advantage of systems because that's not
as important in the culture they came
from. And so the culture where the
person is giving first in order because
they expect something back, the other
culture will just take advantage and be
like, look at this idiot. He just gave
me some free stuff. And so you have to
make sure that basically you're within a
culture or society that reciprocity is
the norm. But if it is the norm, there's
huge amounts of things that you can use
from a persuasion perspective. So the
beauty with how we structure reciprocity
is that people are more sensitive to the
fact that they gave something and you
give something. What's more difficult is
ascribing the relative value. So let me
give you an extreme example. Let's say
that I take someone's order from the
counter and I bring it to the table
where we're both eating lunch, right?
The person might say, "Thank you for
doing that." If I then said, "Hey, can
you pick me up and drop me off from the
airport tomorrow? I mean, I did get you
your lunch yesterday." The thing is that
it poses, it looks like, it smells like
reciprocity, but the value of those two
concessions are wildly different. And so
the idea is that we're trying to trade
concessions in a way that is still
advantageous to us. What I like to do in
terms of my thinking, like the example
that I gave in terms of multiple
simultaneous offers, which is why I
think this works well post that is that
I try and break each of my things into
as many different pieces as possible so
I can trade more times. So, like this
house example that I gave you earlier,
if I have 15 million, but this thing is
going to be financed. Can I go cash or
financed? I can do closing period. I
could say it's a 90-day close or a
30-day close. That's going to be
significantly more valuable. I could say
furniture versus not. There's other
terms that we can basically weave into
the deal that I'm not going to play all
those cards at once. Now, this one is a
real estate track. This is much more
straightforward, but a transaction like
this, it's like you want to think what
are all the variables? We want to use
all the value equation variables. Speed.
How can I deliver this faster? How can I
do it slower? We've got the actual price
obviously. On top of that, we have the
risk associated. So, who's going to be
taking on more risk in this situation?
And what are the different types of risk
that someone's taking on? Then we have
ease. How can we make this easier or
harder for the other person? For each of
these components, you want to take
whatever you're offering, whether it's
an employee or whether it's a vendor or
whether it's a deal. I want to look
through each of these lenses and think
how can I have more variables at my
disposal so that when it comes to the
horse trading I can make a small
concession in ease and they only have
two variables and I've got five and when
I have five I can give without changing
my price and say hey I'll do 15 with
ease they'll come down from 17 to 16 and
I say cool I'll do 15 with ease and risk
and then they come down from 16 to 15.5
and I say cool I'll do 15 with ease,
risk, and
speed. And so when we do it like that,
then all of a sudden it's like I'm still
keeping the reciprocity, but I just have
more arrows in my quiver. When you're
sitting down at the table, you want to
think through all of these different
variables that you have at your
disposal. For me, I have this big deal
sheet that has 80 different things that
I can change about a deal so that when I
go into the conversation, I have so many
things that I can move flexibly to make
my offers more compelling without the
unstated assumptions that people all
have because the thing is they're
assuming the deal just has these two
things, then everything else is the way
they want. And for you, you have 80
other variables that you're like, "Oh, I
can change this one. I can change this
one. I can change this one." And that
allows you to stay in reciprocity with
the other person that ultimately gets
you a better deal long term. So as we're
thinking through this, it's if we sit
down at the table and we have one or
multiple other offers that we think are
really compelling and interesting and we
use that as our psychological power so
we can anchor super high and we anchor
low in terms of our counters, right?
Anchor high in terms of our initial,
anchor low in terms of our counter
offers and then we have multiple
simultaneous offers that are either
presented to us or that we can present
to somebody else using more variables.
and then horse trade with reciprocity so
we can stay in the pocket but still more
or less stay the same initial offer then
we're probably going to increase the
likelihood that we get a good deal done
number five is framing I would say this
is most important especially for
employees and vendors less so for
partnership type or like M&A type stuff
but it can probably also be important
here too but I'll just give more use
cases in these two right now so if we're
talking about framing then how we
position something is going to matter a
lot so if I'm an employee selling to an
employer, which is fundamentally what
we're doing. I would probably say
something to the extent of we want to
make investments in these places and I
see me coming in as an investment, not a
cost. And ideally, if we frame this as
how am I going to get a return on this
investment, then I'm no longer a cost
center in the business at all because
I'm just a percentage commission
essentially on what I'm bringing in the
business. If I'm a vendor, to the same
degree, I'm going to try and frame
something as an investment. I'm going to
frame it based on return, not based on
overhead. On the flip side, you always
want to reframe the other way, which is
you want to reframe this as cost. You
want to reframe this as overhead, so
that ultimately you have more basically
negotiating power because you're pushing
them down. They're anchoring themselves
up. A lot of times people don't even
understand framing. And so they'll just
accept the frame that you present. So
rather than saying, "Hey, this is going
to cost you five grand," we can say like
for $5,000 investment, you can see
$15,000 in maintenance cost savings.
That's very different than this is going
to cost five grand. If that's the
reality, then it's going to be far more
compelling and far more likely person's
going to accept your offer. even though
functionally it's the exact same thing.
I was talking to a few home services
businesses that do like kind of
construction stuff. And so I talked to a
pool guy, talked to a patio guy, I
talked to an awnings guy who did like
awnings on top of patios and I said, um,
do you have any data that shows resale
value of homes that have awnings versus
not? Or do you have any data on resale
value of the specific neighborhoods that
you're going to go into of pool versus
not pool? If someone knows they spent
$100,000 on a pool and adds $100,000 to
their house, I'm like, then the pool's
free. Except you get to enjoy the pool
the whole time. So this we shouldn't
even be talking about that because
you're really just taking it from one
pocket and putting to another. You're
the one who gets to keep the pool. I
don't keep the pool. It's all for you.
So the idea here is how we frame it. If
you're going into these things that cost
you 100 grand, that's a very different
frame than your house is currently worth
a million. The other houses that are
selling at 1.2 all have pools. It's
going to cost you a h 100red grand for
the pool, but you're going to add
$200,000 in home value. what are we
talking about? It's a very different
conversation. So, tactically, when
you're in one of these situations, we
want to have the data to support our
argument for whatever our framing is.
And typically, it's going to be some
sort of return, especially if it's a
monetary thing, right? We want to frame
it in terms of what the is. And so, the
strongest position is look at the other
10 houses that sold in this neighborhood
or look at however many deals that have
been done. They all had these
components. The ones that didn't suffer
this sort of loss. And you know what?
Maybe it's not a 1:1 ratio. It cost you
100 grand and the houses with pools,
it's an extra $50,000. Okay, let's not
frame it as 100. We can frame it as half
off. But you also get to enjoy the pool
for that whole time. And so if you think
you're going to sell this in however
many years, you want to enjoy it and
barely pay much at all over that period
of time. Probably rock and roll. If you
like this video, you're going to love
the 13 years of brutal business lessons
that I have learned over my career. And
dry.